c'est vous la main innocente
[Applaudissements]
attention
ah non boule ça n'est pas toi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout
non vous
non non ça n'est pas
toi non
[Applaudissements]
quand même
besoin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
très drôle qui gère
à toi
[Applaudissements]
oui pour ça ça va toi oui comme ça sera
toi oui bonne chance à toi oui
ça va toi
[Applaudissements]
frère les gars ce sera pas le 26 c'est
faux cette boule
cette boule
est magnifique
dans cette boule il y a un numéro et
derrière ce numéro il y a un candidat ou
une candidate qui va peut-être gagner
5000 euros car
oui boule ça sera toi oui cool ça sera
toi oui bouge ça sert à toi oui d'où ça
sert à toi oui
[Applaudissements]
oui
ça sera toi
à quel moment on se dit qu'on est dans
la secte
et là ce soir 20 minutes sur les boules
c'est super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
qui sera à mes côtés dans quelques
instants ce sont quelques secondes
pour gagner peut-être
5000 euros
cette personne elle est derrière un
numéro
qui a le numéro 65
65 c'est qui il va dire ça n'est pas toi
[Applaudissements]
le numéro 23 allez chérie le 23 c'est
toi ma chérie
allez je vous donne le vrai
c'est un numéro dans les 70 quel numéro
70 numéro 70 ça n'est pas toi
numéro 71
71 le monsieur là-bas
72 à côté ça n'est pas toi
73 ils ont bien mélanger avec toi je
suppose que tu as 74 ils ont super bien
mélanger 74 ça n'est pas toi 75
75 le 75 le 75 c'est toi ma chérie
ça n'est pas toi
79 pourquoi tout à l'envers comme ça
79 mon chéri 79
77 pour toi non 79
79 non c'est pas toi
toi
[Applaudissements]
de commande aussi pour les prospectus
pour la BNP tout ça
ça va sinon
ça va bien tu habites où mon chéri
j'habite à Méru dans l'oiseau j'adore
vous connaissez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sache qu'il ne partagera pas si bien les
5000 €
avec moi viens avec moi ça va aller
faire du bien t'inquiète pas mon chéri
je suis très content de te voir Janick
qui a des achats
merci ça veut dire parler à Janique
voilà Janique mon chéri j'adore en plus
tu es venu j'adore ta tenue j'adore ton
personnage
mon chéri
tu vas devoir
mettre le ballon dans le panier
si tu veux
tu pourras choisir moi une autre
personne pour t'aider c'est-à-dire
m'aider
si tu le mets tu gagnes les 5000 € si
malheureusement tu ne mets pas c'est le
public qui gagnera un énorme cadeau pour
tout public
[Applaudissements]
pas du tout
et c'est 5000 euros voilà reviendront
peut-être un autre jour j'ai pu
débloquer 5000 euros je me voilà
j'ai fait du basket
[Rires]
[Musique]
voilà
attention derrière c'est là la distance
attention joue pour 5000 €.
alors attention là tout privilégies tu
privilégies de style privilégier
l'efficacité
vas-y mon chéri
non non non tu mens tu
[Applaudissements]
menson il est comme ça
il a le droit de me solliciter
[Applaudissements]
j'ai une pensée pour ma famille
Janique je vais jouer pour mettre ce
panier et pour te donner moi-même 5000
euros est-ce que tu te rends compte dans
quel monde on vit
c'est vrai
vous êtes loin quand même c'est loin
c'est trop loin
et ça sera ta dernière chance
je connais un gars qui a un pote à moi
je sais pas s'il est dans le quartier
mais je peux peut-être l'appeler
est-ce que Rudy Gobert est dans le
quartier
[Applaudissements]
c'est un immense champion Rudy c'est
joli c'est peut-être le plus grand
sportif français et peut-être de tous
les temps parce que Rudy il est
tellement humble qu'on peut parler mais
c'est vraiment jolie c'est une sommité
c'est un mec qui voilà c'est une star
aux États-Unis c'est une star partout je
suis tellement heureux
[Rires]
alors là un mètre 90 déjà
c'est incroyable camping 3 Daniel Moreau
non mais c'est fou c'est fou
[Rires]
Rudy finaliste bien sûr de l'euro de
basket l'équipe de France qui a été
formidable on embrasse tous les joueurs
de l'équipe de France et Rudy je
voudrais le dire encore voilà je sais
que je sais pas s'il y en a qui suivent
le basket mais je vous dis c'est
vraiment peut-être la plus grande star
du sport français c'est énorme voilà ce
qui fait aux États-Unis c'est une
immense star et Rudy c'est vrai que je
suis toujours pas ta gueule tu es
tranquille tu fais ta vie donc je te
jure c'est incroyable et tu sais que je
t'ai vu tout à l'heure parce qu'on s'est
vu tout à l'heure on s'est croisé dans
la rue et ouais et j'ai vu je lui ai dit
que j'avais beaucoup cette petite de
cette nouvelle couleur j'ai regardé
pendant les matchs j'ai kiffé j'ai dit
mais quand je le verrai je lui dirai
Rudy je sais que tu vas jouer pour
Janick
Janique tu le regardes on dirait que tu
le menaces
le menace pas les gens j'arrive
en ami Rudy le panier des
si tu mets le panier gagnera 5000 € si
tu mets pas le panier
par contre si tu le mets pas faut que je
mette de haut d'ici
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas le même hein
déjà c'est pas mal déjà attention
[Applaudissements]
si tu ne le mets pas Rudy
malheureusement Janique verra les 5000 €
sont voler et l'ensemble de sa vie
[Applaudissements]
tu as un ami c'est vrai donc je vais
faire une dérogation
je vais te laisser 3 essais
supplémentaires
[Applaudissements]
sixième médaille international pour Rudy
j'en ai pas fini avec toi
à côté de moi juste avant
je voudrais revoir des images de contre
la Tunisie contre la Turquie l'équipe de
France ça cartonné d'ailleurs la finale
sur M6 dimanche soir regardez
le sacroche mais comme trop souvent les
balles perdus s'accumulent en face les
Turcs qu'on retrouvait leur basket et
affiche maintenant une adresse insolente
malgré tout la France est toujours dans
le match dans les ultimes secondaires il
suffit d'un panier pour forcer la
prolongation le flotteur
[Musique]
il y aura encore une balle de match pour
les Français au moins pour aller
chercher la prolongation Thomas Heurtel
Thomas Heurtel avec la place ça rentre
c'est rentrer bon je viens de loin on
ouvre
[Applaudissements]
je voulais voir ça
le contre de Rudy c'est incroyable
tu as un nouveau club maintenant et bien
là-bas où ça dans ton nouveau club
écoute j'y vais dans quelques jours ça
t'est bien tu as pris tes marques et
tout super content parce que ça a été
quand même le transfert on dit transfert
on dit pas transfert là-bas on dit quoi
on dit draft c'est ça
mais bon ça c'est tout le monde en a
parlé donc la théorie
ce nouvel aventure donc on va l'objectif
c'est d'être compliqué
maintenant voilà j'ai des super souvenir
maintenant faut passer à une étape une
étape supérieure le stade différent je
pense ça va être énorme Valérie ton fils
doit être content d'avoir
Yannick j'ai une question à te poser tu
as gagné 5000 euros
mais ici tu sais rien ne se passe comme
ça
c'est où tu gagnes ces 5000 euros
tu rentreras chez toi avec ton papa avec
quelqu'un vous connaissez non non
quelqu'un qui tu vas faire qui tu vas
faire connaissance
ou bien
tu décides de renoncer aux 5000 euros et
là un superbe coffret évasion non en duo
pour tout le public séjour repas
au public donc
la production si vous avez un problème
vous allez voir Lionel Stan
le directeur général l'âge de zoo s'il
vous plaît on vous a pas demandé votre
avis vous le demandera tout à l'heure
vous aurez des petits pancarte vous le
donnerai est-ce qu'il peut faire le
téléphone à son papa pour savoir son
avis quand vous serez productrice dans
l'émission
pour l'instant je veux qu'il prenne ses
décisions seul Janique
c'est quelqu'un qui était en grande
difficulté scolaire en troisième
[Rires]
il doit prendre sa décision seule alone
et bien c'est avec regret que je dois
renoncer à faire plaisir au public je
vais garder les
[Applaudissements]
alors si tu veux tu peux bien sûr alors
le public il a pas son cadeau il a plu
quand même bien sûr faire un tour et
faire un doigt à tout public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci et aussi merci voilà aussi vas-y
aussi vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y mets ton
père vas-y
Janick a gagné les 5000 €
et le public le public n'a
malheureusement rien gagné merci à eux
d'être venu
ça va aller bah oui mais les chéris on
peut pas c'est pas la fête on peut pas
tout donner on peut pas tout de même
tout gagner voilà Rudy était formidable
tu vois tu l'as malade
ils s'en fout totalement voilà faire en
trois pattes je peux t'offrir un coffret
évasion
[Rires]
pardon deux jours
il faut que tu m'invites un jour
je reste avec lui
je suis content je voudrais dire encore
une fois et
fantastique il a été élu dans le 5 les 5
meilleurs joueurs de l'euro vous le avez
fait rêver contre la Turquie et l'Italie
la Pologne alors il y a une petite
déception que vous avez parce que vous
avez perdu en finale mais toute la
France a révélé de cette équipe
fantastique de basket bravo
il est juste venu nous voir voilà Rudy
il nous a fait l'honneur de venir nous
voir je voudrais qu'on remercie qu'on a
pas eu très fort rudy Gobert cet
après-midi merci mon Rudy d'amour